hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
previously on this channel we've covered
the current battery revolution
extensively from Samsung's graphene
battery promising five times faster
charging coming to phones as early as
2022 recent battery research
breakthroughs - an exclusive interview
with an industry expert in battery
recycling in all of this the company
that has come up the most is Tesla love
them or hate them they were the pioneers
of the latest iteration of the electric
car
they forced innovation from industry old
guards like Porsche and Jaguar which is
great this isn't to mention their
batteries used in industrial settings
such as balancing power grids Elon Musk
last year
claimed something especially outlandish
a new battery that could last for over a
million miles critics thought it was
impossible but a new study may prove
that it is possible and indeed is coming
in this video we'll learn about what's
going on you are watch for cold fusion
TV
in April of 2018
Elam claimed that Tesla would soon have
a battery that can last for a million
miles or about 1.6 million kilometers
the current battery pack is about maybe
300 to 500 thousand miles of the new
battery pack prolly going to production
next year is designed explicitly for a
million miles of operation the entire
vehicle battery pack occlusive it is
designed to operate for a million miles
with minimal maintenance maintenance
after this amount of use it will still
have over 90 percent battery health
remaining to put that into context
that's two times the current lifespan of
Tesla's contemporary batteries we'll get
to the details of the battery in a
second but Eva's claimed this could put
electric cars in general in an
interesting position
[Music]
according to NBC news a regular petrol
car lasts for about 150,000 to 300,000
miles before something breaks that makes
it not worth repairing when you think
about it a regular petrol powered car is
actually pretty complicated it needs
regular maintenance to keep it
operational and it's unavoidable that
some parts just wear out after a given
amount of time problems like a slipping
automatic gearbox or a blown head gasket
can be expensive to repair and can take
a car off the road permanently electric
cars are much simpler with the only
major moving parts being the electric
motor and usually a single speed
transmission with these new batteries
this all means
electric cars could last longer than
their petrol counterparts it goes
further than this though as you've
previously seen in the battery recycling
episode rub the industry expert I
interviewed for the piece stated that
electric vehicle batteries have much
more life after being used up in the car
they can then be used in power
management to support a grid and after
that lower and lower power consumption
requirements until they can finally be
recycled with a battery with twice the
state-of-the-art lifespan this opens up
a whole new world of opportunities ok so
let's take a look at the battery itself
a physicist by the name of Jeff Don led
the research of the new battery which
was vastly superior to any other
lithium-ion battery previously seen Jeff
is already a leading expert in
lithium-ion research him and his team at
the owl house eat University has an
exclusive licensing agreement with Tesla
this suggests that this technology could
appear in the company's cars the details
of the paper are pretty extensive it
includes the full cell design including
electrode compositions electrolyte
mixture additives and more the team's
results show that these batteries can be
charged and depleted more than four
thousand times and after this they only
lose 10% of the original energy capacity
to put this into perspective a 2014
paper showed that similar lithium-ion
batteries lost half their capacity after
only a thousand cycles
according to the study headed by Jeff
which was published in September 2019
the 1 million mile figure is equivalent
to two decades of in grid energy storage
what's interesting though is that the
authors of the paper
don't Herald this all as a new
breakthrough they present it as a
benchmark for other battery researchers
this is the opposite to common practice
usually battery designs are often a
closely guarded secret within the evie
industry providing this information to
everyone aims to help other companies
improve their own designs for the future
he is acquired by the authors of the
paper quote full details of the cells
including electrode compositions
electrode loadings electrolyte
compositions additives etc have been
provided this has been done so that
others can recreate these cells and use
them as benchmarks for their own R&D
efforts end quote I think this is great
news this research was done to further
the progress of battery technology not
just for one group but as a whole for
everyone and I think that's a noble goal
[Music]
generally speaking there's usually a
trade-off between energy density and
battery lifetime if you want more of one
you get less of the other Jeff's group
was responsible for doing the seemingly
impossible they overcame this trade-off
now you can have increased energy
density and battery life interestingly
the materials used in the paper
aren't you the huge performance boost
was achieved through a great deal of
optimizing already common battery
ingredients they also tweaked the nano
structure of the batteries cathode to
increase performance the new nano
structure is less likely to develop
cracks when the battery is charging
cracks in the cathode material caused a
decrease in the lifetime and performance
of the battery and this happens during
repeated charging cycles basically the
new cathode and this new battery will be
able to resist more wear over time
Jeff Don estimates that most Eevee users
is only about a quarter of a charge per
day but to make something like a fleet
of Robo taxis or an empire of long-haul
electric trucks Tesla would need a
battery that can handle full discharge
cycles each day this could really make
electric long-range or long-term
transport of many kinds much more
feasible so with so many stories of
battery research rapidly coming forward
it seems like we're at the start of a
new age an age different from the
previous decade where battery technology
stayed stagnant if you do want to see my
previous battery room videos including
the state of better recycling I'll leave
a link to my battery playlist below and
just a quick update while making this
video some other battery news just broke
researchers at the University of
illinois-chicago have made a new carbon
dioxide battery that holds seven times
more charge than current lithium ion
methods that published their findings in
the journal of advanced materials so if
this video does well and you do want to
see a video about this new tech I'll be
sure to make it so thanks for watching I
really appreciate it
don't forget to check out the cold
fusion podcast and also follow me on
Instagram and Twitter anyway this has
been - go go and you'll be watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video cheers guys have a good
one
[Music]
cold fusion it's rethinking
[Music]
you